there's a lot of interest in the uae
because
it's a very pro-business jurisdiction
they're very interested in innovation
not just in crypto but in all fields for
example they have the most advanced dna
sequencing lab in the world i was able
to visit that facility and actually have
my dna sequence they did it in 10 days
and as a result
i think those of us that are involved in
investing in crypto are very interested
to hear directly
from the government
the unique thing about the uae that
people don't understand and while i was
there i was very fortunate to get my
citizenship is that
it's a small enough environment that you
can get direct access to the regulator
and you can have an open dialogue with
the regulator regarding what the
policies are it's extremely interesting
and entrepreneurial there's no other
region like it on earth
and so when i think about my crypto
investments uh cryptocurrencies are a
global phenomenon they're not really
governed
uh by border they're governed by
regulators and policy makers and so you
really want to keep
going to these regions and finding out
what direction the policy is going to go
and i think
like canada and switzerland
and germany
they're very advanced in the uae and so
i'm extremely interested in making more
investments there and i spent a fair
amount of time there a total of 10 days
and i see it as a place it's sort of the
switzerland of the middle east
it's where you want to set up your
operations and where you want to service
that part of the world which is growing
very very quickly so i'm interested in
working with turkish citizens egyptians
moroccan iranians iraqis
and you can do that out of
out of abu dhabi
so what is your current investment
thesis on crypto if you have to broadly
describe what is your investment
theories on the crypto industry right
now
look at
crypto not as coins or tokens i look at
it all as software
it's productivity software
the the the projects that are going to
last and and
be here you know a decade away from now
are ones that actually solve problems so
let's let's give an example i'm an
investor in polygon you know i'm very
fortunate guy i i i'm able to call up
the leaders of these projects and these
teams and they returned my call and i
asked to meet them anywhere in the world
in this case we met in dubai
with the polygon team
i'm an investor in in software engineers
i always have been i've been in the
software industry for 20 years
they're very very strong and their
mandate what they decided to do is to
try and reduce the cost
by sitting on top of ethereum and
aggregating transactions so the gas fees
are a fraction of they would be if
you're doing one at a time i thought
that was a brilliant strategy and i made
an investment in polygon
the same with solana the same with with
ethereum the same with you know hbar all
of these are software
and they they all have different
attributes if you're investing in for
example in google or in microsoft what
are you investing in you're investing in
software why wouldn't you invest in
crypto it's software too and in the case
of crypto just take for example circle
and usdc usdc takes a lot of pressure
and reduces fees in all kinds of
different ways
and in the case of staking gives you
some kind of yield against inflation so
all of this to me is just software
engineering and i have a broad portfolio
i'm very familiar with the engineers
involved in each of these projects i
support them i'm an advocate for it and
the regulator is is in my view
going to eventually support these
initiatives because of the tremendous
economic enhancement and productivity
they provide for the underlying economy
and
as far as the u.s regulators concerned
they have the opportunity to lead the
globe in policy whether it be stable
coin whether it be bitcoin whatever it's
going to be and i don't think they want
to give up that opportunity they just
want to get it right and those of us
that are waiting for their decisions
are very optimistic because you can look
at this two ways you can say okay the
regulators are getting in the way of
growth
that's one way to look at it i don't
look at it that way i look at it saying
when the u.s regulator makes its policy
the floodgates of institutional and
sovereign wealth are going to pour into
these crypto assets and i want to be
well positioned before that happens i
don't know when it's going to occur
it's not a matter of if
it's a matter of when and i'm very
optimistic that they will take the lead
and provide policy for global regulators
that's what i believe it's very
interesting to see your statements right
now because when i
um in the past uh we have been looking
at your conversation with pampliano a
few a few years ago when you were
accusing him not accusing him but you
were basically prohibiting him to hold
the
cryptocurrency um it was very funny we
used that bite a lot in our videos to
represent you as like
the uh
crypto uh contrarian by and now you are
you are a completely different story so
that's pretty cool i remember that video
i remember that video and i and i and
paul plays it every time i go on a show
the point was at that time the regulator
was very uh
non-constructive on cryptocurrencies and
we were discussing this in a highly
regulated environment but anyways look
i've changed my mind you're absolutely
right
i'm a huge advocate and a supporter and
most importantly an investor
okay um so now that you are an investor
you you told about a few of your of the
crypto you are invested in you you
told about polygon you talked about
uh solana ethereum so talking about
specifically your portfolio in crypto uh
can you give us a bit of an overview
portfolio in terms of uh do you hold do
you all like nfts defy
metaverse what is your
if you can give us some details about
your portfolio construction
yes um
in individual tokens and coins and
chains i've got 33 different positions
wide range of diversity you know i look
at this the same way i look at managing
an equity portfolio never more than 5 in
any one name never more than 20 in any
one sector so
in that theory that mandate means that i
can go up to 20
in crypto right now i'm just over 10
about 10.7
but i've also made equity bets
uh for example i i have a an investment
in wonderfuy a canadian company that is
democratizing defy so they're providing
they're launching their product in
january they've been working on it for
over two years
one of the biggest challenges for the
individual like my daughter or my son
who wants to do staking and remain
compliant with tax authorities depending
on what jurisdiction they're in
is it's very complicated to actually do
it if you have fourteen thousand dollars
in your bank account and you decide that
you'd like to stake some of it
wonderful is working very hard to make
that very easy to do
and and that that's one of my
investments because i think crypto
currencies are not just for the crypto
elite there's a huge demand within the
population to solve for the fact that
interest rates are so low so just on
staking alone that's a huge opportunity
number two i became an investor in
immutable holdings which is jordan
freed's company why because specifically
he's working he owns a domain nft.com
now normally i would not put a lot of
weight
on a domain except in the case of
nft.com there are so many s p 500
companies that have nft strategies that
want the domain nft.com forward slash
fill in your corporate name so he's
going to be curating that
i'm an investor in that as well and yes
i own individual nfts i think
for example i'm a big believer that nfts
which are basically digital wallets of
information are going to be very big in
the physical asset world one
specifically
that i'm part of the advanced thinking
on if you want to call it that i'm
funding a white paper on it right now is
for the watch industry
the watch industry as you may know
is one of the fastest growing asset
classes in the world right now
multi-billion dollar secondary market in
trading fine timepieces and we don't
have any nfts for authentication and
insurance purposes
we want that and and so do the so does
the watch industry so the idea would be
if you take a high resolution scan of
the dial you can identify that watch in
perpetuity and you could avoid uh
fraudulent trading of a piece that was
made to knock it off and that that's of
great interest to all the great
watchmakers
just my collection alone i want to do
that on so the whole point is there's so
much activity on nfts and yes i'm an
investor there
the the whole concept here everything
we've just talked about is all software
i keep going back to that i look for the
best teams i invest in their companies i
invest in their tokens their coins their
currencies but it's all just software
what is your
video on bitcoin has your uh has your
view on bitcoin changed since you became
a crypto advocate
uh and how
yes i have a position in bitcoin it is
not my largest it is close it's up in
the top quartile though um ethereum is
larger than bitcoin right now for me
um
here here's
i'm a huge advocate for bitcoin i treat
it
as an asset no different than a triple a
office tower in boston
it's a it's an asset i don't consider it
a currency now everybody has their own
opinion my opinion is it's an asset so i
hold it i'm not i don't trade it i do
stake it but the point is i'm not
selling my bitcoin the challenge i have
with bitcoin and the whole industry has
this challenge is we've got to deal with
these esg issues there's a lot of
criticism around bitcoin because the
amount of energy it takes to get a coin
awarded
and in that area i'm working very hard
there's lots of initiatives to create
bitcoin and i'm not saying we're
bifurcating the bitcoin market that
onecoin's different than the other but
if i'm at a sovereign institution and i
work with lots of sovereign institutions
because i'm in the indexing business
they would like to fund
bitcoin mining where they keep their own
awarded coins knowing with 100 certainty
that they they mine them in an ethical
and efficient
sustainable manner
and that is where a lot of the new
capital is going whether that be wind or
solar or nuclear or whatever
those all of those projects are
happening globally and they're being
funded by sovereign wealth because
sovereign wealth has esg and
sustainability committees on top of
their asset decision making
so the next generation of coins awarded
are probably going to be held in
perpetuity on balance sheets of
companies that are
funded to make them sustainable and you
know
that's one way to solve that problem
at the end of the day i would argue that
bitcoin mining is at the forefront of of
efficient energy use it really is
it's just that the rest of the investing
world doesn't take that view
and there's been a lot of criticism of
what happened in china initially by
burning hydro carbons to create
electricity to make coin and you've seen
all of the controversy in the last year
now at the bitcoin 2022 conference
i think there'll be a lot of good news
in this area that's going to happen in
february as you're well aware but it
will definitely be the topic of
discussion yet again
but
since then
hundreds of millions of dollars have
been earmarked and exactly put into the
ground into projects that are going to
be more sustainable in wind solar and
nuclear as i mentioned in different
geographies west texas is a big focus
right now obviously but there's other
geographies that are also looking at it
so that's the next big thing for bitcoin
but i i why wouldn't i want to own that
for the for the the long term i mean i
just think the long-term prognosis for
that
is to own it beside gold as a hedge
against inflation
all right that's interesting but still
that's not your biggest crypto holding
and that's quite telling it means that
you believe that for example ethereum
you mentioned that you owed more
ethereum than bitcoin it has a larger
growth larger growth potential than
bitcoin in the future i guess no but it
doesn't say that i don't like bitcoin
what's happening though a lot of the a
lot of the innovation that's occurring
within the software engineering you've
got to remember something the hottest
hands the best developers in the world
have moved over to crypto you want to
find the smartest engineers in software
development you're going to find them in
crypto so again i go back to polygon
polygon's working with ethereum they're
working with it to make it more
efficient and so you know i look at my
polygon investment as a quasi-ethereum
investment because what they're doing is
aggregating transactions they're making
ethereum more efficient many people in
financial services are concerned that
ethereum's too slow
and that's why they're looking at solana
for example and so that you know you
have to make multiple bets you can't bet
on just one horse in crypto you've got
to go with the hottest teams with new
innovation new ideas and which is what i
do and i again i say i'm so fortunate
because
you know i have direct access to these
individuals and that's probably a little
bit to do with
you know uh the work i do in the media
but it doesn't matter what what matters
to me is what can i do as an investor
how can i how can i support their
initiatives
and i believe there's a direct
correlation between social media the
media and market capitalization my
ability to help a company tell a story
really matters so if i can get millions
of followers as i have and explain to
them why i'm doing what i do and why i
support these different teams i think
it's it's of everybody's benefit that's
good
companies have ideas engineers have
ideas they have innovations people
should understand what they are
i really i recently took a position in
helium i'm intrigued by the idea of
providing you know low-cost wi-fi on a
global basis
to democratize it to make it uh less
expensive in all kinds of geographies i
like that idea it's a great initiative
why not own it and
let the managers and the miners around
the world
do what they're going to do but there's
an economic reason to own that it's
driven i always believe the best ideas
are driven by economic
momentum something you're some problem
you're solving some efficiency you're
creating some productivity you're
providing
that gives you the long view and so is
it you know i'm a little bit more
focused on enhancing productivity
economic value than let's say
uh you know meme coins that i have less
of those in my portfolio although i do
support potherium because i'm involved
in cat dna
dna research i own sympotherium uh i
think the fact that they give back to
animal shelters is good
um but you know that's that's just one
of the meme coins that i'm involved in
because there's a there's a reason to do
it uh people know that i'm an investor
in base paws they're probably the most
advanced dna company for cat health
uh it's been a very successful a company
and um there's a there's tying together
the crypto world with the the real world
of dna testing and sequencing
ah and
[Music]
yeah that's cool so if we had to now
describe the uh percentage of your
portfolio that is now in crypto you
mentioned that
you wanted to get to 10 by the year but
at the end of the year but that's not
about your personal portfolio it's about
your
your companies
let me be specific i said i started the
year at three percent in the operating
company uh in fact we're sitting at 10.7
today
so we have gone beyond our target
only because many of the projects have
appreciated so dramatically
most of this is held in my ftx wallet
um it's the platform you got to remember
something that
people just don't spend enough time
talking about in this industry and i and
i lived it
when you are when you have your own
compliance department and you have an
external auditor and you have to file
with the regulator regardless of what
geography you're in doesn't matter
you need you need infrastructure you
need compliance infrastructure for
example when i trade a stock if i trade
a stock in in
when i get off this call with you and i
trade a stock in zurich or in london or
somewhere in the eurozone
i mark to market that position
instantaneously
my compliance people can see it
instantaneously at the end of the day
when market closes they can
see exactly what percentage it is of the
overall portfolio that the mandate
allows between three and five percent
waiting they'll know they'll know
immediately if there's leverage on the
position everything is built into that
compliance infrastructure and has been
for decades every institution works
under the same mandates
we have nothing like that in crypto we
we have archaic methodology where we use
spreadsheets to calculate percentages
and we're constantly going back to look
at the transaction in the chain and the
auditors are freaking out because they
can't see it and they can't mark to
market and the
i mean this is this is a big problem
it's a really big problem so when you
tell me well you know do you think
institutions are going to buy bitcoin or
any other that the truth is they are not
even present yet in the crypto markets
and the reason they're not because they
don't want to be because they have no
way to do it on a compliant basis so
you know the most advanced companies in
providing compliance platforms and
infrastructure in my view it's a
personal opinion
are ftx and circle and so i was able
after six months negotiating with my own
compliance department and my external
auditors to open an account with circle
and start to stake usdc
same thing with ftx months it took
months and months and months but now at
least i have
my own internal team
that can work with my own internal
compliance and external auditors this
stuff is a nightmare and it's not going
to get fixed overnight and it's the
biggest
problem
that's holding back the advancement of
pricing of crypto currencies and chains
we got to solve this problem
we have to fix this problem and
and the regulator wants us to fix this
problem and the institutions want us to
solve this problem
that's what i think the next two years
is all about
okay and then now i have a question for
you about uh about that but first i
would like to know um so you said that
you you are reached around
10
of the portfolio but you say that
every investor could invest up to 20
into a specific
sector so uh i would say i would ask you
what should happen in the regulatory
atmosphere in the u.s to convince you to
bring your allocation
into the crypto industry
well again this is a personal opinion
what i really want to have happen is i
want the regulators
to
bring policy forward
on stable coins that's what i want i
want because stable coins are very
important to me
as a hedge against inflation and
specifically the one i've chosen to work
with is usdc because i think it's the
most advanced in terms of in dialogue
with the regulator not here but in
geographies all around the world
it's a form of payment
it's also a form of of hedging against
inflation because if i can at least
marry
my staking program with inflation
currently at six percent at least i'm
holding value
but i can't really do that until the
regulator rules because
even within my own
operating company with my own compliance
department
they're considering uh stable coins as
an equity no different than a stock so i
really can't get past five percent it's
not like i can hold a huge 30 cash
position i mean you know when we sold
off our commercial real estate we had a
huge cash position we couldn't
it was about 30 of the operating company
so you know we've been working hard to
redeploy that capital but i i really
want the regulator to rule on stable
coins now you know that there's been
some controversy
with certain stable coins with the
regulator i don't touch any of that
stuff
anything that's involved in in a in a
fight with the regulator i have i want
nothing to do with i am not a crypto
cowboy i work in a compliant environment
i don't want to get on uh you know some
kind of a mission saying we have to sue
the regulator that's insanity that's
crazy and and that's really bad idea and
so uh i think all of us in this industry
should understand that we work with the
regulator
to to generate the most advanced policy
we can get and that the reason we do
that it's in our self-interest of
sustainability and also it gives us way
more
in terms of what institutions can
allocate into these asset classes so we
should definitely be thinking about that
and that's interesting because you
choose stable coins as one of the main
tools to
to get interest on your on to get value
out of your out of your assets while
cash if you hold cash you end up losing
value uh but a lot of people would say
why don't you use bitcoin then in order
to um
uh in order to keep uh those uh higher
those high returns instead of stable
coins why do you choose stable coins
instead of bitcoin well the challenge i
have and many institutions have with
bitcoin is volatility so when you are
managing or your fiduciary for for
capital volatility is not your friend
because you're marked to marking value
of the portfolio every 24-hour cycle so
if you're been given a mandate by an
institution
uh and you most of these mandates are
based on diversity and stability your
number one mandate is preservation so if
you're managing for a pension plan or
university or state fund or whatever it
is
that volatility really hurts you when
when you're being graded in terms of
your mandate and so i don't think you're
going to see
um there's nothing wrong with putting
bitcoin in in a five percent waiting up
to a five percent waiting and treating
it like an equity um or an alternative
that and i see tremendous interest in
doing that from a one to five percent
generally on average a three percent
weighting with where you find bitcoin
but you're not going to get there uh to
a 20 30 in bitcoin in an institutional
or sovereign mandate you're just not uh
stable coins have that potential if they
were regulated and specifically i think
the stable coin of choice currently
uh at least for me is usdc because they
seem to be more
um
you know jeremy ellard who's sat in
front of congress recently seems to be
more in tune with what the regulator
wants and is is willing to be very
compliant that gives me some it doesn't
mean it doesn't guarantee me anything
but it gives me some assurances that
uh he gets the joke so to speak about
compliance
you seem to be pretty confident that the
regulators will eventually enable crypto
to thrive
on the other hand there i had a
conversation with with mark yusuko a few
a few months ago who was
expressing this very common narrative in
the crypto space which goes like
um there are the incumbents of
traditional finance like banks
uh
and the final financial intermediate
intermediate intermediaries that are
going to
lobby the regulators or still use their
influence
to slow down this this crypto evolution
that we are looking forward to happen so
don't you see the role of the incumbents
as a major issue for for encrypted to
develop further and to get the
regulators on on their side
i don't
i don't agree with that positioning i
don't think that's going to happen
either the only
entity that can control the pace of
regulation is the regulator themselves
and it doesn't matter what the
incumbents say or do they will they will
go with the flow of productivity and
innovation and if just we've you know if
you
all of these different uh chains and and
uh all of these different tokens and all
of these ideas for
uh currencies are all in very innovative
and so
whichever ends up winning if you want to
call it that way or gets majority of
market share
all of the incumbents will fall in line
banks don't set policy
they
operate under policy and and so
it's they have a they have a say in it
they can talk to the regulator and they
do and there's nothing wrong with that
and they're an input but no one bank is
bigger than the regulator and banks you
know are winning and losing all the time
in terms of who makes more money who has
a higher return on assets
i can tell you what motivates a
traditional
money center bank is return on assets
they they spend their whole day trying
to figure out how do we optimize for
return on assets and
if they're not looking at
cryptocurrencies they'll be left behind
that's what's going to happen because
when the regulator finally rules just on
if it was just on stablecoin alone they
would have to open a stablecoin desk of
course they would now are they going to
start from scratch or are they going to
be working on it quietly in the
background my guess is they're working
on it quietly in the background they
would be foolish not to be
as you said inflation in u.s is hovering
around the six percent points and the
fed now intends to win down the stimulus
measures
uh
in order to contain this uh trend
so how are these macroeconomic
dynamics going to impact the crypto
industry the crypto prices in the months
to come according to you
i use you know if you it's a great
question because if you asked it just 60
days ago i would have said the majority
of the inflation that we see in the us
economy right now is driven by the fact
that the supply chain is broken i have
investments in over 30 private companies
and i'm well aware of the situation we
have right now regarding supply chain
issues so if you're manufacturing in the
us as we are in many of our companies
our supply chain is broken to lower cost
components so we're having to source
them domestically at a 30 price increase
and we're passing that on
to our customers and that is why i would
have said inflation
was temporary i don't believe that
anymore
inflation is now uh where it is
in major commodities like energy like
gasoline like food prices because we
have over stimulated the economy
we have we have printed so much money in
the last 24 months
you can argue was it was important to do
that during the pandemic but the
pandemic is rolling on as you know it
has different uh luckily vaccines are
helping manage it
but supply chains are still broken
but really what's happened is there was
just too much stimulation and and as you
saw yesterday
um
the buildback better plan is dead and
that's very good for for the american
economy because that was stimulation
that was going to be inflation on
steroids that was a very very bad idea
and as a result the check and balance
system it doesn't matter which side of
the aisle you're on bad ideas never make
it forward that was a bad idea but now
dealing with real inflation it's going
to put much more pressure on the whole
system to find solutions particularly
for cash holdings
you're you're being taxed at effectively
six percent if you hold cash maybe you
don't want to call it a tax but when
inflation six percent your buying power
12 months from now is six percent less
and that's a lot
and so
we now have added pressures and i'm no
different than anybody else trying to
figure out where do i deploy this
where can i get stability in the in this
cache where can i find a way to hedge
and it brings me all the way back into
stablecoin so i'm a huge advocate for
solving this problem with stablecoin it
doesn't mean i don't want to invest in
the other blockchains or the other coins
or tokens or other ideas i do
but
i can't i can't do 30
positions in mandates of of any of them
that's too volatile so
these issues are not going away the
dialogue is not going to change you're
going to see
a lot of discussion about this in the
first and second quarter
of next year and you're right on the
money to be covering this there's no
question this is going to be very
important
and and i think we're going to start to
see some moves with the regulator very
shortly not just in the u.s
you we opened this interview with united
arab emirates we talked about canada we
talked about germany talked about
switzerland the same those regulators
are all talking to each other they're
all talking to each other if we could
just agree on one stable coin between
those jurisdictions that would be huge
productivity enhancement and i
anticipate that will happen if you like
that video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe